good morning members
good morning members of the public
you're all very welcome
to this morning's meeting the baby
district council's plan committee
um i'd like to welcome you all here
first of all may
remind you of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones and
cameras are turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you wish to speak point of order
declare a point of declare and interest
or requesting a german please use the
hands up function
on the taskbar members are reminded that
they should not have
alternative communication lines open i
and that if you are contacted by a third
party during an application you should
bring this to the
linda keenan
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
if members do lose connection to the
meeting
they must contact the member support
officer mandy smith as soon as possible
you all have that number
we will be using modern.gov to connect
to conduct all electronic votes during
the meeting
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting
will be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewings
the hold of the meeting book will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt paper items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council
and to the possible use of those same
recordings for webcast
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and press may
record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and press are not lawfully
excluded
i'd like to introduce the area planning
manager
mark russell planning lawyer indie press
governance officer robert carmichael and
case officer
samantha summons
members i'd no longer move to the agenda
and the first
item on the agenda is substitutes and
apologies
uh robert do we have any
robert carmichael
all right i think you're you're muted at
the moment
you seem to have lost your apologies
chair all right
we can see you in here you know oh you
can hear me it's still showing us mute
on my apologies
um we have apologies today from council
alice's knowing
thank you and there's no substitutions
is that
yeah thank you all other members are
present
per our papers right item number two
decorations of
interest do we have any
i see no hands going up so i'll take
that that we haven't
item number three to confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on the 24th
of march
members
uh councillor barrett
uh thank you chair um sorry just adjust
um i just wondered whether we should
include a recorded vote uh
for all members as it's it's recorded
who
proposed and seconded each item
but it's not recorded who uh how other
members voted i just thought in the
interest of
perhaps total transparency and fairness
to to each member that that should be
uh disclosed to the public in the
minutes how each
member voted um
good point um robert what is our normal
procedure on this
thank you chair can i can i be heard
just to check yes yeah we can hear
i'll go talk slowly if it's having
connection issues the
um so in the minutes that are before you
that is not included however all of the
votes that members have taken and how
they are voted are recorded on the
website
um it's part of council procedurals and
subcommitte
committee and subcommittee procedure
rules that
for them to be recorded in the minutes
we need to would need to go for the
extra step at the time of a vote
for um the propose for a proposal second
and one other member to request a
recorded vote
however i would draw members attention
to the fact that all
votes are now recorded on the website um
and can be viewed
um under the items um as required
under the vote that was taken and the
motion that was put to council
um earlier this year with regards to
that
right so uh and members then
unless it's requested at the time of
photon for a recorded vote which would
be listed in the minutes
um it can't be done afterwards
it's just on the website is that correct
hello i think linda keenan might have
joined us i will just
i'll just pause
i'll just put you on mute until the
appropriate time thank you very much
okay uh counselor barrett did you want
to
come back you heard what it said uh yes
um
okay it never reads very well does it
when it's like it was oh you have to
admit i
i read it and i thought exactly the same
as you
it's just that you can you can sometimes
come in for an awful lot of criticism
from the members of the public who
disagree with the way you voted
and the the person who proposes or
seconds
um gets the lion's share of that
um and and it's just a bit unfortunate
really um that people don't always go
and
and check that out uh fully as to how
other members
vote but um oh yeah i'll leave leave it
for the moment then i think that's some
uh perhaps a matter um counselor barrett
that perhaps
we should take up um with the leader of
the council and the monitoring officer
to see whether we
we need to change the rules or um
do anything at all about it well um i
think
it's a it's a good point because uh when
i read that
i'd like to know in the two that uh the
the abstentions that happened
um and um going on the website saying
where i can find out well i
i must admit i haven't had time yet to
do that
and most people will think the same i
think so i think do you have a point
i i would suggest you take to carry it
forward in the appropriate way
thank you thank you um i've got another
couple of hands up um we're on the
minutes um
councillor osborne
thank you thank you mr chairman i've
just proposed that
we uh accept the uh
application thank you thank you
i'll see if i'll get a second um because
i've seen another hand canceller
um heirs yes and i was second
the minutes you're coming up very just
as a black
outline we can't see you at all well
that's no shame with my face
never mind okay thank you
uh second any other comments members
there's two hands up if they can go down
thank you uh right there members um i'll
ask robert to take us
through the procedure for the electronic
vote
thank you chair um i would ask members
just to bear with me
one moment as i believe i don't think
it's just
myself but i think the system is running
quite slow today in all respects so if
members could please go
to the modern.gov app and go to today's
gender
they will see in the top right hand
corner a plus sign
if they go to the plus sign and click on
that and click on the subsection of
attendance
voting they will then see the
voting tab and the light blue line which
shows the vote in progress
and then i gotta come down and close
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is 10 votes for
thank you very much right we'll move on
members
um on item
[Music]
four which is um to receive any
notifications of petitions
uh robert do we have any none received
yet
thank you very much item five is site
inspections
are there any site inspections officers
that you request
no question thank you mr russell
uh members are there any site inspection
requests
no hands up so i'll take that note thank
you very much
we'll move on then to item number six
and that's planning applications for
determination by the committee
and we'll go to 6a which is upper street
liam
and the case officer is samantha
all right samantha summons
would you like to take us through the um
application thank you thank you very
much i don't seem to be able to share my
screen at the moment
right i don't know if um robert or mandy
can anybody help
what is it showing sam is not giving me
the option it says only meeting
organizers and presenters
i can sort that out chair no problem
well done
this modern technology is brilliant when
it all works
we just need some young people who are
more than capable of keeping us on the
track on the straight and narrow tracks
of it
could you try that now please sam yep i
will do
just take a moment to load up
um so this app this presentation will
cover two applications for the same
proposal
for planning and also list of building
consent
members will debate and vote on each
application separately
the applications to be considered are
for the erection of extensions to
provide
additional facilities including
reception
banquet wellness center and additional
bedrooms to the marquis
formerly the marquis of cornwallis in
layum
in addition to the extensions the philip
planning application includes the change
of use of the adjacent agricultural
field to create a new car park
and formal garden these applications
come to committee
because they are considered to be
controversial with
149 objections from 84 different
households
and 55 letters of support the parish
council has objected
and the society for the protection of
ancient buildings have also raised an
objection
this conflicts with the view of our
heritage expats
no other objections have been received
by statutory consultees
i apologize there is a mistake in the
description of the proposal in your
agenda
the first word should actually read
erection
liam is divided into two clusters uh
which is separated by the river brett
um can you see my cursor yep yep
that's okay um uh the marquis
is located um in in the upper layer
which is this cluster here which is on
the b1070
and that is the main road between hadley
and
uh the access for the a12 at halton
saint mary
hadley sits to the north of upper lamb
and can be accessed easily by foot or
bicycle
along a pathway excuse me
liam is classed as a hinterland village
oh sorry
um in the core strategy that has limited
facilities which includes
marquis in upper lane the queen's head
and the church in lower land and the
village hall sits roughly between the
two
the hatched area shows the application
site
windy ridge is a private dwelling which
sits to the south of the site
just here and during the
course of the application has been
purchased by the applicant
uh marquis is located to the north of
the site
in this area here with the nearest
neighbours being in
old orchard which is this road here
the application site is shown in red and
includes the existing hotel
and car parking area
so the existing hotel is here and this
is all the car parking area
and there's an access point on the 1070
just here
the rest of the application site
is here which is a large field
that wraps around windy ridge but it's
only this
outlined art that forms the application
site
uh the agricultural field has a uh
agricultural
classification of grade four which is
considered to be
poor quality for farming
the marquis comprises of two listed
buildings
a public house and a cottage both the
grade two listed
and form one building the site is wholly
within a special landscape
area the site is elevated from the river
brit
which runs at the bottom of the site on
the western boundary
just here
the flood zone which is the blue
hatching
uh extends towards lower layer the
majority of the site lies
outside of the built-up area boundary of
lamb which is defined by this
brown line along here
this is the existing layout of the site
the current owner purchased the public
house in 2015.
the premises had sat empty for a number
of years and the building has
had fallen into disrepair the owner has
invested considerable sums of money
into renovating and extending the
building to form a boutique hotel and
restaurant
so these are the two listed building
here and these are the extensions
that already exist uh
these areas here are the terraced
outdoor areas
and there's also a separate building
here which is used as a bridal suite
the access point and large car park
are located just here which sits between
the existing hotel
and the agricultural field which is
wanting a change of use
this aerial photo shows the site marked
in red
with the dwellings of old orchard to the
north here
a farmyard to the east
just here and windy ridge the private
dwelling which is now in the same
ownership as the hotel
to the south here the river runs along
this tree line
a useful point of reference for the rest
of the presentation
will be this access point to the farm
track
which is roughly in line with the
existing
access point
this is the proposed layout um the
existing hotel
is just here with the outdoor terraces
and the bridal suite building here
uh the existing access point is just
here
and the car park the existing car
parking area
is roughly here
so um the extension would be built on
the existing car parking area
the new car parking area which is along
here
would be kept to the top of the site a
formal car parking area
just here with the access point but also
an informal
uh grassed car parking area just here
which would be fenced and would have
gates
these would be open during uh events
where extra parking would be required
a formal garden is proposed um
just south of the oh well it's west
actually
it's because the uh drawing is turned at
the moment
so uh at the bottom of the car park
there's a formal
garden proposed
landscaping includes considerable tree
planting
along the boundary with windy ridge
and also around this formal car parking
area and garden and
also some grassed areas
here the landscaping
is intended to screen the car parking
from far
reaching views across the valley a
substation
would be positioned just here in the car
parking area
so that's easily accessible
this is a street scene which shows the
front of the hotel with the proposed
extension
shown just here so this is the existing
hotel
this is the extension that is proposed
the arrow shows the existing point of
access
which is to be stopped up the existing
iron railings would continue across in
front of the new car parking area
and the new access point is at the end
here with windy bridge
just here
one of the major planning considerations
of the proposal is the impact of the
scheme
on the listed buildings and also on
their setting
the extension is very large the
architects have worked very closely with
heritage throughout pre-application and
also during the course of this
application
the main concerns raised are the
position
scale and bulk of the extensions
it was very important to design
something that is subservient to the
listed building and would be suitable
for an edge of village location
the extension has been set back from the
listed building
um this is the original listed building
so uh the extension has been pushed back
so that you can see this gable end
here um and the ridge
is actually set below the existing
listed
building ridge
the extension uses the land levels which
fall away to the river brett
to put the highest part of the building
at the lowest level on the hillside
so this is what how they've managed to
get
three stories in to sit
under the listed building height the
roof has also been broken up to help
reduce the bulk of the extension
the existing hotel is shown just here
and this is a view of from the road
frontage
so as you can see the ridge has been
dropped for the extension
considerably and also set back so that
you can read
this building as the original listed
buildings the extension has a simpler
design
with the end section giving the
appearance of a maltings building
similar to those as snake moltings
the rather large brick gable has been
broken up with brick detailing the
bottom drawing
shows the rear of the building with the
original
hotel on the left hand side so it's all
of this section here
and the extension is this here this
is the bridal suite that is existing
you can see how the building uses uh the
levels
to make it sink into the landscape the
road
level can be seen just here where the
iron railings are
the heritage team have identified less
than substantial harm
they have classified this as a very low
level of less than substantial harm
and this is mainly to do with the
location
of the substation within the car parking
area
the architect has confirmed that this
cannot be moved because of
access issues the hotel has
been renovated to a very high standard
and this is to be carried
on with any future development that is
allowed on the site
the design and materials are considered
to be acceptable
uh the lesson substantial harm raised by
the heritage team
refers to the substation this is a 2.4
meter high cabinet that is three by
three meters
in footprint this cabinet is located at
the front of the site
the substation cannot be moved because
of access issues
this is the existing ground floor plan
of the hotel
the reception area is currently at the
back of the hotel
it also shows the
the terraced areas just here the
diners and drinkers use when weather is
fine
and this is the bridal suite here all of
this area is
the existing car parking area
the current footprint shows the
restaurant area
kitchen meeting room two bedrooms
two lounge areas a bar area and
informal dining toilet facilities are
here
uh this is the existing first floor plan
of the hotel which has seven bedrooms
this floor is not accessible to people
who are less able-bodied
um the same goes for parts of
the ground floor which are on different
levels and there's steps to negotiate
this is the ground floor of the proposed
extension
so the original hotel is just here
and then you can see the stepping back
of the extension
the extension includes a new reception
area
an office a lounge area
a bedroom and this
is the events or banquet hall
the extension also includes a lift which
accesses all floors
uh this is the first floor
um of the extension and uh
shows a further four bedrooms
uh at this level here this is just an
open void above the
um exist sorry above the banqueting hall
a basement level uh the wellness center
is proposed along with lavatories
a storage area and kitchen
the applicant has invested heavily into
the hotel
and has kept busy going during the
pandemic with food deliveries
he also took advantage of the eat out to
help out scheme in august which was very
successful for him
the applicant feels that he needs to add
something to his small
boutique hotel to make the business a
destination hotel to encourage
more visitors he has received queries
from people who wish to take advantage
of the beautiful setting for their
weddings
due to the size of the existing kitchen
and restaurant this is not possible at
the moment
the extension is extensive and would
increase the floor area of the hotel
from 882 square meters to
220 square meters
more than doubling the existing hotel
the car parking and access raised no
objection from highways
ecology was raised during the
application
both water bowls and otters use a river
brett and so
surveying of both species have taken
place
in order to protect the habitat of both
species a wide area along the riverbank
will be kept as a habitat protection
zone
which is shown with this hatching area
here
all of this brown area is proposed to be
laid down to a wildflower meadow
considerable planting of trees is
provided to screen the car park
this is an important feature of this
scheme because of the elevated position
of the land the development is within a
special landscape area
objectors have raised concerns over
noise potential
a noise assessment has been carried out
and reviewed by environmental protection
it is noted that windy rid bridge which
is the nearest neighbor to the car
parking area
is now in the ownership of the applicant
in terms of noise impact on the
neighbours
in old orchard the car park has been
moved away from them
and the extension has the existing
buildings between them which form
a buffer mitigation measures
are in place for noise leakage from the
extension
and is considered to be acceptable
moving on to some photographs this is
taken traveling from hadley
towards raiden old orchard can be seen
here on the right
and the hotel is just here with its
extensions
going back here
this is taken from the bank in front of
old orchard
and this is the existing hotel
this is the hotel the iron railings seen
at the front here
uh would continue along the field
in front of the car parking area
moving past the hotel along the road
this is the existing access to the hotel
which is proposed to be stopped up
you can see how the land falls away
towards the river
this is windy ridge and the field that
is proposed
for the car parking area and formal
and informal gardens
this is the field uh which would become
the car park
and the landscaped area with windy ridge
just here
the bottom of the field would become the
wild flower meadow
and habitat protection zone for the
protected species
and you can just see in the distance
here lower layer
this is taken looking back at the hotel
the cable end
and the black weatherboarding would
still be visible with the extension
being set back
and down from the listed building
this clearly shows the bridal suite
which is just here
the extension would form a u-shape
wrapping around here
development would go no further down the
hillside
than the bridal suite
this is traveling towards raiden and
looking back at windy ridge with the
hotel site behind
which is pretty well screened with the
existing trees
this is taken from the other side of the
valley at lower layer
the pink house is windy ridge and the
site
is tucked in here
this is taken from lower liam and you
can clearly see windy ridge the pink
house
and mainly in this picture the roof of
the hotel
just here and the car park
this is just moving a bit further
towards lower lane
and you can see windy ridge here this is
the field that is proposed for the car
park and landscape area
and formal garden this is the existing
car park that would be built on for the
extension
and you can just make out the white bits
of the hotel
again windy ridge and the field fever
developed
and this is the existing hotel and the
car parking area
windy ridge the field car park
and um the hotel so the extension would
come out here into the car parking area
this is an aerial photograph showing the
existing hotel
the terraced areas uh the bridal suite
and the car park
this shows the relationship of the
nearest neighbor in old orchard
to the hotel
[Music]
this is the car parking area of the
hotel that would be built on this is the
bridal suite
this shows the car park and existing
buildings
um this gives an indication of how the
landscaping would look
um it currently looks like this
after one year following planting it
would look
like this and after 15 years
this is what it is likely to look like
the same thing from the rear of the
building so this is what it looks like
at the moment
this is after one year
and this is after 15 years of
development
uh just for ease of reference this is
uh a comparison of the existing at the
top
and the proposed layouts of the two
the application site is outside of the
built-up area boundary
however this is an existing business
that wishes to expand
the proposal would be supported by
policy em-20
of the local plan which encourages
expansion of existing businesses
and policies cs15 and cs17 of the core
strategy
as it makes provision for tourism and
leisure-based
businesses which form important economic
revenue streams
the proposal does not raise any issues
of highway safety
landscape impact ecology impact or
residential immunity impact
that cannot be resolved by conditions
for mitigation the less than substantial
harm
identified by the heritage team has been
balanced against the public benefits
in this case the public benefits include
the retention and
expansion of an existing business that
would create a further 24
time and 20 part-time jobs this would
result in a total of 55
full-time and 45 part-time jobs
which is a significant number for a
small rural village
there would be a good number of jobs
provided during the construction phase
of the development
the proposal would secure the future of
the hotel for both visitors
and local people who may wish to use it
as a hub for
upper lame um these public benefits are
considered to outweigh
the less than substantial harm
identified
therefore this application is
recommended for approval with conditions
as set out in your agenda
thank you thank you very much for
that full report we've got an echo
somewhere oh it's gone good um
right um now
ask the members is there any points of
clarification members that you wish to
put to
the case officer uh councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman just a quick one
samantha the
a lot has been made of the positioning
of the substation and its size and bulk
etcetera
and the fact that it can't be moved
because of access reasons
where is it at the moment
we cannot hear you samantha
you need to unmute
i'm sorry i i'm not sure that it
actually has
a substation currently i think because
of the size of it
that's why it is required
so why is um for instance
it not considered that it could be put
at the end of the car park on the
uh the route towards uh raiden it could
be put further away from the building
because if it's a new new construction
and a new facility
then putting uh cabling and so forth to
it and then
at that end of the car park it would be
perfectly accessible
um i'm not too sure and it's probably a
question
that either the architect or the um
applicant may be able to answer for you
because i think um councillor hinton
that question
could be put to the applicant and their
agents
um because i don't think um we have the
answers to that at the moment do we
samantha
no we don't
i'll bring you in um and get you to ask
that question when
when the applicant speaks or the agent
okay
uh cancel i was born
thank you mr chairman first of all can i
compliment
samantha on an excellent report and
presentation
the report that i've read through uh has
covered
more than more than the normal details
which i've experienced over the years
it is really uh really fantastic
um just getting back onto john hinton's
thing with the substation not
there's a question i was going to ask
about that and
what i'm what i'm suggesting perhaps is
that
are the feeds to the uh substation
coming overhead or underground
because that that would be the the
uh problem with the the polls at the
moment is the
current uh uh supply to that
uh proposal overhead or underground yeah
the proposed substation
would have to have a feed from from i
think
uh there's there's telegraph poles going
across the land so it's
overhead but i'd just like to have that
confirmed please
can you help samantha's just another
question for the
think yeah i think it's probably a
question all right so keep that one
cancel
i was born for the applicant you've got
a second one
so yeah yeah it's just about the surface
water uh
uh situation from uh from that site
is any of that sub is any of that
surface water
uh from possibly the drains does that
go go back in does a lot into that water
go back into the river brent
uh which is uh obviously not too far and
the other point of that is
have you any any idea of how far
with all the water we've had just
recently how far that water came up
uh on that flood zone please
um should i can you still see the
presentation
yes we've got slide 39 okay let's go
back
so the flood zones are shown here you're
quite right councillor osborne uh the
brett
is uh a flooding area and that does
happen on a regular basis however
because the site
is elevated uh the water doesn't creep
up
that far um so not within
the car parking area at all just at the
bottom of the site there
uh it tends to use the uh land on the
other side of the river as the flood
zone because it's much lower
in terms of surface water that is
something to be
sorted out through condition
the floods authority haven't actually
raised an objection
they just wish for some uh conditions so
that will be sorted out at a later stage
should members
approve the scheme thank you
councillor parker you chair just
returning to the substation quickly um
sam you did give
um a dimension in your presentation and
i tried to scribble it down but
i didn't get to it quickly enough did
you you say 2.4 meters can you just um
2.4 meters in height and uh
three by three meters in footprint
i threw me some footprint okay so if it
was a shed it would uh
constitute um permitted development but
okay thank you very much cheers
yes good point thank you uh councillor
barrett
thank you chair um just uh wanted to to
ask for a little bit of clarity on the
the tree planting um
samantha um it says in the report
significant tree planting
does that mean the size of those trees
or the maturity
or the the sheer number
uh yeah both actually um
yeah there's quite there's a lot of
planting going on at the moment it is
just an agricultural field so
it's fairly barren uh so all of this
area here is to be uh planted in trees
and also around the formal garden my
understanding is
that the applicant does already have the
trees
and is ready to plant them at any time
and they are quite big trees um
the actual final details of them will be
uh
will be agreed by condition uh because
of the mix
we wanted uh a specific mix in terms of
landscaping
because it's just interesting to know if
they're the sort of the um
uh there is a an existing tree that you
can
that has been shown in the diagram yes
and that's a really
mature you know probably
60 meters high isn't it but it will
be in time similar variety that would
reflect
you know echo that throughout to this
sort of uniformity
so perhaps i'll ask the uh the applicant
themselves
yeah i think our landscape officer
they've um actually specified
uh the species that they want um
and that would be to complement native
species
uh for the ecology on the site
sure okay thank you okay thank you uh
cancer jameson
okay thank you chair um there's a
condition
for external lighting could you expand
on what those conditions will be at all
please
uh they will need to write in uh with
the specified lighting
uh to make sure that it's wildlife
friendly but also that it's not going to
disturb the neighbours in terms of light
pollution
uh just standard conditions that we use
so
does that relate to the landscaped area
yes so the position we'll need to see
the exact positioning of them
i think it's unlikely that there'll be
anything in the landscaped area
it will be to do with the car parking
and
probably around the reception area at
the front
and perhaps some on the terraced area
again
perhaps uh the applicant could give you
more clarity on that
okay thanks okay
thank you i don't see any more hands up
so there's no other points of
clarification
members thank you members we'll move on
to the public speakers
uh first up is um lion parish council
uh john curran um you sir have three
minutes in which to address the
committee
which would be tied by the government's
officer so
when when you're ready it won't uh time
won't start until you start so
when you're ready um you may carry on
thank you thank you thank you land
parish council object to the proposal
50 of the 161 public comments have been
from residents
objecting to the proposal with only
three residents supporting it
they fear that the extensions will
change the character of the village
and will bring increased noise light
pollution
and traffic as a parish council we've
analyzed each part of the proposal
and agree with our parishioners that the
proposals will make lamb
a less desirable place to live you
already have our detailed objections
which are based on recognized standards
and take into account
all the revisions that have been tabled
our main objection
is the size of the venue which will
dominate the skyline
and increase the noise and other
pollutants to our quiet village
lamb upper lamb's population will double
when the venue is in use placing a large
elevated wedding terrace at the top of a
natural
amphitheater means that even moderate
noise will travel
across the normally very quiet brett
valley disturbing residents
we applaud the intentions to keep music
inside the building
by keeping the large bifold doors closed
but question how this can be policed
on a hot summer's evening wedding guests
leaving late at night will talk and slam
car doors
which will be intrusive to the sleeping
residence
cars exiting onto the narrow winding
b1070
will meet traffic traveling far faster
than the 30 mile an hour limit
speeding has been such an issue that the
parish council is installing a speed
indication device outside the marquis
there are currently 73 car parking
spaces
yet the proposal is to increase this by
only 29
to cater for an additional 120 seater
wedding venue
a leisure complex extra bedrooms
and up to 40 new staff we feel the
parking will be inadequate
and vehicles will park along the narrow
b1070
or in residence areas light pollution is
already a problem
and the fear is that no matter how dim
the lights are
or how they are directed the bigger car
park and grounds will worsen the
situation
apart from the marquis lamb is a dark
skies area
with no street lighting for more than a
mile
to conclude we feel that the current
size
and activities offered by the marquis
benefit the village
but the proposals are disproportionate
to the village's size
and whilst offering possible job
creation will be to the detriment of its
character
bringing unwanted noise light pollution
and road traffic thank you thank you
very much mr curran
i'll see if there's any questions from
members for you
members do you have any uh comments or
questions that you wish to ask
the parish representative
no there's no hands gone up
thank you mr karen we'll
move on i'll just ask the case officer
was there anything that you wish to
uh comment that you heard in that
statement
uh yes i'd just like to confirm the the
parking
uh is actually policy compliant and so
the county council highways have not
objected to the scheme
thank you very much thank you we'll move
on
uh we now have a um
uh objective to speak richard cranfield
uh you you sir have three minutes also
in which to address the committee
um the time will start uh when you start
speaking
thank you thank you very much um
i'd just like to make four points i
think the first one is
um why are we here and i think that
the the truth is that notwithstanding
the investment which has been made into
the marquis
it's lost a lot of money it's lost uh
well over a million pounds over the last
three and a half years
three and a half years uh and the
operating company the marcus or
cornwall is limited is only survives
because
of support from shareholders as and is
technically insolvent and so
um the question about these jobs and how
sustainable
they are is a very open one and and
understanding the investment may be made
uh
i'm not sure you can guarantee in any
way at all that
there will be a sustainable business
if you look at some weddings um over the
last 47 years you can get from the ons
statistics for england and wales that
weddings have declined in number by 43
percent
so the demand for meddings is is
dropping notwithstanding the rise of
population
in lamb itself there's basically been
113 in the last 70 years so these are
not local weddings
and there are within close distance
13 other currently existing
local wedding venues and so i would
suggest
that to the extent that weddings are
attracted to the marquis
they may well be taken away from other
businesses in himself
kersey you know the tall booth
all around here so so i think that
i i would suggest that the the reason we
are here is because
um demarcus is not trading profitably
and it's a doubling down and i think
that the the site
is a huge expansion three acres
expansion
uh the building is uh overwhelming to
the holistic building
and so i object on that basis thank you
very much
thank you very much sir uh i'll just see
if members have any questions for you
members do you have any questions to the
objector
no i see no hands gun up
i'll take that then that there isn't any
questions to you sir so we'll move on
we'll now uh ask the supporters to speak
linda karen you have three minutes in
which to address the committee
and the time will start once you start
so if you'd like to turn your camera on
and then chairman can i say my hand was
up i had difficulty putting my hand up
oh sorry uh you you've got a question
for the objective
yes i did actually right i'm sorry i
difficulty putting their hands signal up
um hang on a minute uh linda can you
please hold back for one moment and i'll
ask the objector you've come back good
um would you like to put your question
counselor mccarron i would
um you uh mr cranfield you obviously
have done a lot of research in the
numbers
and and the impacts and the business
success
in terms of the employment that is
promised
in your view the the people
of the village are probably not going to
be part of the people applying for jobs
where do you think those people are
going to come from
if they were going to be employed by the
hotel
uh i i think i struggle really to answer
that question
um because i i i it's there may well be
people
who live locally who will get employed
and would be able to
to to get there but um that obviously
some people the numbers concerned must
mean that there be
people coming from a distance um i think
my real point about employment was that
the losses are just not sustainable and
you're just relying on the shareholders
of the company to support it
and i think life shows that over a
period of time
these things change i think councillor
mccarran the same question should be
put to the applicant sorry
yeah yeah no i think um the objective
has
uh been very fair and tried to answer
yes but i think
perhaps you might get more from the yeah
um agent
right okay thank you i will now
go to the supporter to speak linda karen
um you have three minutes perhaps you
turn your camera on and your mic on
please
all right i can see you can't hear you
at the moment
you're mates um you're unmute yourself
yes hello can you hear me yes i can hear
you
although your mic is saying us on but we
can hear you
yeah i'm i'm speaking on the phone yep
that's fine
as owner of the property nearly opposite
to the marcus
and two other properties in close
proximity
i have a strong interest in the future
of the markets i am a supporter of this
development
the proposal continues the tasteful
upscale style
in which the current marcus was
renovated i can honestly say that i've
never been disturbed or even much aware
of any activity generated by the marcus
and i'm surprised by the objections
raised because as i read the proposal
the expansion would substantially
improve
some of the shortcomings in the current
situation
for example the car park which i agree
does not enhance the landscape
when viewed from across the river would
now be hidden
noise from the functions which now have
to be held
outdoors or in a marquee can be taken
inside
and the lighting will be redesigned to
be more subdued and
unobtrusive visually i would rather look
at an attractive building constructed in
traditional style
with artisan bricks than the current car
park
but these considerations are details and
i would think that any issues could be
dealt with by appropriate conditions
accompanying the approval the most
important consideration is the economic
reality of the situation
we lived with a derelict pub for way too
long
and it benefited no one the model of the
small local pub
is no longer viable as evidenced by so
many closing
each year we must accept that another
kind of business model is required
i can understand that the ability to
hold functions such as weddings
is essential to the viability of the
business
to me a successful marcus benefits the
community in many ways
the employment opportunities it offers
are obvious
but remember many of these jobs are
given to local kids
seeking their first ever employment
there is the added footfall to hadley
with knock on economic benefits
and the sense of pride the community can
derive
from having a thriving attractive
establishment in their midst
the owner of the marcus is hands-on he
has shown his desire to be a good
corporate citizen
and his willingness to double down with
increased investment
shows his commitment and optimism about
not only the
markets but the community in general
certainly through this horrible pandemic
one thing we have learned is the
importance of community
and how much we are all interlinked our
success is
linked to our neighbor's success it is
in our own
interest to realize that we should
support and encourage the success of the
market
now is not the time to be short-sighted
or parochial
the alternative to a successful marcus
does not bear contemplation
thank you um i'll take that you're
finished just
just a few seconds before your time
thank you very much
um i'll just see now there's any
questions can i just ask one can you
just clarify
where boats do you live you said
opposite or near i live in lamb hall
which is
just uh slightly down the hill across
the street
right thank you just so we're clear on
that
members have you got any questions to
the supporter
no hands going up
no thank you very much uh we'll move
on um we'll now move to the
applica application the applicant to
speak stephen o'leary
and will hardwick we have three minutes
in which to address the committee
uh so perhaps um linda you can turn your
camera off
thank you and now perhaps can um stephen
uh turn his camera on and his mic please
good morning i guess i can see you can
yes we can hear you okay your time will
start when you start speaking
thank you i'd just like to thank
everybody for turning up and
providing me with this opportunity to
speak um
obviously um was was uh
was was run down and empty for some five
or six years
um when we purchased the building we um
then uh went with a local architecture
of the village
to try and turn this into a thriving
business
um as we've progressed through uh the
last three years
it was apparent to me that we needed to
have some other reasons why
people from outside of the area would
would like to come and stay here
and to that end we decided to
uh to work with the planning
department um to design a building
um that would um support itself
um including the restaurant um and today
to that end
we we designed the wedding venue with
um a wellness center spa um
underneath it um obviously
um during the planning process we've
um changed the design to
fit um the the older part of the
building
and um to try and
not spoil other people's
views of this area
the the process has been um quite
a long-winded one because um my
understanding of
of planning was not that great and so
i've had to work with
a specialist to get to where we are um
we end up at the moment with a with the
use of the
the original building and the rooms only
being um
30 of the time and so we
believe that by extending the building
and having the wellness center we can
utilize the uh the
rooms that we already have to a greater
percentage
and then obviously we're expecting to
receive other people
the the wedding venue itself um is
uh came to fruition because of the
amount of people that have asked if we
could do weddings
and without trying to spoil our regular
customers it was going to be impossible
so
those are the reasons why we've gone
with the extension as it is
the the i purchased the the field next
door
um and so that enables me to shut down
and and and uh turn the
the ugly looking um car park um
into a formal garden i think um
if if if we'd have had more comment from
the um
from the parish council and or people um
prior to this application we would have
probably done more planting
anyway but um in the in the three year
period that we've actually been open we
have not received a complaint about
noise
light or anything else thank you very
much mr o'leary
your time is up thank you
i'll just say i think there'll be
questions for you
perhaps you could keep nearer to your
mic so we can
hear you clearly that we could hear you
better
um there'll be more going on now uh
right i've got
uh i'll take an lee inaudib
thank you chairman and good morning mr
o'leary
um i wonder if i can just ask you one of
the previous speakers
uh mr cranfield made much of the um the
fiscal position
and and obviously we're not here to
consider
financial positions merely the planning
merit of the application that's before
us but nonetheless
um you'll appreciate that if members are
minded or were minded to support this
application
it is going to uh it's going to change
uh the the landscape uh here
forever um so um i just like your
comments mr cranfield mentioned that
um this application amounted to a
doubling down
um so i'd i'd just like to um to hear
your comments on that just briefly if i
made australia
so so um the the turnover of the marquis
and the profitability of the marquis has
improved year on year
to the extent that um the the last full
year of trading
that we had there was a profit on the
business of seven
thousand pounds um that's not fantastic
but obviously um in the first four years
of the business
we have depreciation on all of the
equipment
um that we have purchased in the first
you know 18 months of
building the business so we are going in
the right direction
and i wouldn't be proposing um an
extension which is going to be um a few
million
um if i didn't think that we were going
to succeed
thank you uh councillor mclaren
thank you chair good morning mr o'leary
good morning
um interesting mrs keenan
raised um in my mind
the fact that a lot of hotels are
actually
um employ young people
that's the nation in the nature of the
business isn't it
young people tents and students
um so where do you think
in terms of employment how where do you
think you're going to recruit your staff
from
well i mean obviously we already recruit
and
we recruit from um from from the village
itself
we recruit from hadley we recruit from
east bergo
raiden and capers and mary
and those and those children as well as
adults um that's where they come from
now
and we are actually um
going through a process of reopening on
the 12th
um and and we've got a whole new
generation of youngsters that are going
to come and join us
if um you were recruiting from further
afield
because as as a result of the pandemic
many young people are traveling all over
the country to find work
aren't they i didn't see any facilities
and it might be my mistake um for
staff any staff
so so we purchased windy ridge which is
obviously the
building opposite us and at the moment
we have three employees living in that
building
thank you very much mr o'leary thank you
chair thank you
uh just following on from that point mr
o'leary how many
full-time employments do you think this
will
eventually encourage to be employed
there
i do understand that a lot of part-time
workers will be
would be working there that's uh
understandable but how many sort of
full-time
additional jobs or how many have you got
now so at the moment we have 20
full-time staff and 25 part-time staff
and we expect to employ another 20
full-time staff
and we're expecting another 25
uh part-time staff oh you're dublin
thank you
thank you very much kenzler hinton
councillor hinton come on thank you mr
chairman
um mr o'leary just a quick one i asked a
question earlier on about the
the need for a substation why is there
no substation at the moment but there is
need for one now
and if it's a new requirement why does
it have to be in the middle of the sort
of car park area can't it be put towards
windy ridge that end
so um uh that's not our choice that's
the
choice of the uh of national grid
um i think when when when samantha was
going through her
um her playing you saw opposite the mark
was that there's a lane
and the cable is going to come down that
lane and go underneath the road
and then come across i mean from my
point of view obviously
it's going to be near my reception and
it's not ideal
but it is actually although it's 2.4
meters it's actually sunk into the
ground so it's not as high as it sounds
and obviously what we'll be doing is
covering it up i mean i'm not going to
do all of this and then end up with the
substation looking at all my customers
camouflage yes okay
thank you uh councillor jameson
thank you chair thank you chair morning
mr o'leary
uh the the parish council made comment
about light pollution
yeah and uh no there's gonna be a
condition for external lighting so i
wondered
what um you're going to do to limit or
mitigate
the light pollution and also is there
going to be any lighting in the
landscape area
um so first of all we've already
trialled
um uh low lighting which actually sits
right into the floor
and um we have um directioned
the the lighting and then hopefully with
with shrubs and so on and so forth we'll
be able to
to uh see what the uh
the pollution is and then deal with it i
mean one of the peculiar things is that
um you know obviously we've been open
for four years now
we've got post lighting and um and we
haven't received any complaints about
it but what i did um was go um
to the other side of the valley and then
we've actually
covered up lighting that faces away from
where we need it
but what we what we've done now is take
those post lights out as you drop down
the slope into the car park
and put to ground level in the floor and
so we will continue to deal with that
the the the shame is that if these
things hadn't
had been mentioned to me before then
we'd have dealt with them already
um the light pollution issues only come
up
once we apply planning permission
and is there going to be lighting in the
landscape area down towards the river
oh why not
i suppose the reality is we'll be coming
back to samantha
and and and the planners to see what is
and what isn't acceptable
i mean from my point of view we don't
have well
the the big tree that somebody spoke
about which is an oak tree we have an
uplight in that tree um and that is
outside of the the um the dining areas
that's the only lighting that we have
okay thank you canceler osborne
well thank you mr chairman and uh good
morning mr o'leary
um yeah you've you've actually uh
resolved one of the questions i was
going to ask you which was about the
windy ridge
so i take it that will be for uh employ
employed people that
are going to work there and so that that
will be
extended further i take it in terms of
internal
bedrooms and stuff yeah i think um
sorry yes mr
do you want to ask at that point yeah we
we we were given the opportunity to
purchase
and and it was absolutely ideal because
um
you know for my my opinion is that we're
moving the noise away from the village
and so windy ridge was was would have
been our biggest
um opponent if you like um and so we've
dealt with two issues we already
uh rented two properties in the village
and then we've
reversed out those two properties and
and purchased our own
thank you and one other question um
talk about the parish council um
have you have you had any well
through this application have you
attempted or
have been into the um virtual meetings
with or been invited to the a virtual
meteoroid
uh asked to be a part of the parish
council
area in terms of the comments please
i i've been along to the last two paris
council meetings
and i've actually spoken to mr curran
last week
but prior to that i haven't been invited
and there hasn't been the opportunity
for me to then
progress the relationship thank you very
much
thank you mr chairman councillor ayers
good morning chair and um good morning
um mr o'leary
um i'm interested in in the employment
aspect and you do have accommodation and
apprenticeships would there be an
opportunity to have an apprenticeship or
linkedin college yeah absolutely um
um trying to um
trying to create a menu
um which which um is varied and so on
herself
is is is is difficult and
and so we have um three senior chefs
um and we work with um the colchester
technical college
and where we have chefs um educated now
i mean ideally for me um
if we were allowed to have the new
building
it gives us the opportunity to do more
training on site
and to work alongside the cultural
technical college which is
absolutely fantastic because if i can
train
um and and um promote
from within then i just feel like um the
people that work for me are happier and
i and i work alongside these people if
my general manager's not
and and when you see um
um young girls specifically um
come here with with with anxiety issues
and so on and so forth and then just
watch and blossom is fantastic i mean it
is
probably one of the best things that we
have to be honest
thank you mr leo glad to hear it thank
you thank you chair
thank you and the last hand i've got up
i can't say any others after this which
is counselor barrett
thank you chair um good morning mr
o'leary um well i think you've
heard me mention uh inquiry about the
the trees that you're playing to
the plates um would you like to
give us a bit more
i just um can't hear you mr o'leary
can you hear me now yes yes sorry um
trees are um i live for trees
so so at this moment in time we have uh
planned 172 new um trees which will be
oaks ashes whatever it is that
the ecologist samantha and i can work to
um yeah i mean there will be everywhere
you know it's
it's it's um it i
cannot um have a wedding venue
without the destination so
it is the most important thing um as
i think samantha mentioned i work with a
company um
just the other side of dedham we already
have
150 trees in growth um
because i need an immediate impact
um i was hoping when we started this
process to have been planting in
september
um but because of covid and so on and so
forth we're way out now
so i've now got away probably until next
september but
um be assured there will be more trees
planted than are asked for
you know this this this is about having
a fantastic
venue with with shrubs trees
and views that's what it's about and and
just to go back to the lighting i don't
need
um um to have fantastic lighting when
we've got fantastic views
and fantastic sunsets here already
thank you i'm pleased to hear that
because i think the views across the
valley
as its rising land the the smaller
varieties would not have blocked out
when the
the uh there's a there's an incline um
i did live recently near a a popular
wedding venue
the only time that it was actually much
very noticeable was when the um
parties want to have fireworks sort of
at midnight or
sorry we live in an area where there are
lots and lots and lots of horses you
know
we're not having fireworks we don't need
fireworks we
you know i i think the point is when
somebody comes to me and
and requests um to have their wedding
here
then the restrictions that we put in
place straight away
will it will not affect what we're doing
and the reasons for it
are are really good you know i mean
the lady that spoke earlier misses miss
keenan
and she her horses are here the
gentleman that objected across the river
he's got horses you know
we're not here to spoil pigs i need
these people to come back to the marquis
once i've done this
do you know what i mean yeah and sorry
finally um i just want
there was a question well um i heard
about the
uh treatment along the river's edge the
sort of the
sort of keeping it segregated uh um how
are you gonna safeguard
that so that it remains as a wild area
for
mean i have to work alongside the
ecologists obviously
we've spoken to um the local um
water authority people and you know we
just we just need to work with them it's
not
it's not an issue i mean i you know from
my point of view i'm not an ecologist
i've had to work with we've had to bring
people in to deal with this to deal with
point um place services and so we
whatever we need to do to to to address
the damage that we've done we will do
and and i think
you know the point about trees and so on
and so forth is all relative
you know we need to make sure that we've
got an environment that people want to
come and sit in
thank thank you thank you councillor
barrett i shouldn't have said
you were the last handout because i've
got two more now
so we'll carry on kenzler busby you're
next
thank you chair yeah the county
mentioned that the
the parking spaces were sufficient but i
guess most weddings occur
friday saturday which are obviously your
busy times
anyway are you confident that you can
cope with two peaks one at the wedding
and one of the
dining well we've never filled the car
parks that we've got now
and um and and obviously the greened
area that we've put
um alongside the the
you know the general car parking area
should suffice
if we need to i mean the first thing
that's not going to happen
is people are not going to be parking
out in the street you know i have a very
good relationship with the
with the farmer across the road and um
and when we were
um what we were doing we had to park we
had to park
oh we had a car a classic car
um show and so we parked all the staff
cars across
um in the farmers field in the farmer's
yard and so i mean you know if i don't
see it you know we
we've done the calculations we know
where we are but if if i need to go and
speak to the farmer across the road who
i get on well with whose electricity
supply is coming through his drive
then we'll have a conversation with him
you know and we'll park the staff cars
over there
we've also which obviously wasn't in
this plan we could park another 15 cars
in windy ridge anyway which could be the
staff cars
and just finally uh it sounds like
you've had quite a few conversations
with the planning team
um have the have your designs changed
much since you first started out on this
i i think uh the conservation officer is
the one that um
that that
[Music]
reduced the size of the building we've
we've probably lost three bedrooms
and we've probably moved away from the
road
um you know i think
i i understand um he's got a job to do
and obviously i'm trying to do mine
you know so so we've had to appease that
situation i think
uh i don't under the the village
boundary scenario is peculiar because if
you
actually stand across the other side of
the river the conservation office has
made us drop the building into the land
so actually you can see the farm
buildings behind my building
so it's not as though we've come to the
end of the village and we're plonking a
place you know so
so so we've we've had to work with him
to reduce the size to bring it down
and and um and that's what we've done
thank you thank you it looks a very
sympathetically designed
building as well thank you thank you um
councillor jameson uh yeah thanks chair
again um in terms of the
extension um what are you going to do to
get to
as close or to carbon zero
in terms of build standards obviously
you can't do a lot with the old building
but
the new building yeah i mean that's
that that's an issue that we i mean
because this has been such a a drawn out
protracted
um uh issue we've been dealing with with
with the stuff we're dealing with but
one of the things that we we're going to
do
is we're going to um future-proof the
car park area we're going to run
cables underneath the car park towards
windy ridge
so that um as as things develop
we've got a different uh direction that
we can go in you know and that's
it's it's there isn't anything specific
that that you know power usages and so
on and so forth that i have
been able to get my my my fingers into
but
as we now go to the next stage of
getting them quotes from builders and
then obviously we will be looking at you
know energy usage
um carbon footprint there was a
i was going to try and construct um
with the with the use of of of planting
our carbon footprint neutrality but
um there's clever of people out there
than me that are going to have to do
that
because um i i couldn't you know work
out if
if i was planting and we were taking
over a ploughed field that ed
you know um i i think that you've
answered that question thank you
um okay councillor jameson
yeah uh yeah yeah i mean yeah okay i
didn't really answer
if we're gonna go for fabric first
but um did you want to put put that
other point
um yeah i was gonna say so you get when
you do the actual build you're gonna
actually look at the fabric of the
building or get your builders to look at
that to produce
to be keep well absolutely i mean
you know one of the things one of the
things that is of heavy use
is heat you know so yeah i mean
i need them to look at all of it all
right thank you
there's no other hands up members
um so i'll take it then that there's no
one else that got any more points of
clarification
thank you very much um
mr o'leary uh we'll now move on
um thank you if you turned your camera
off from the mic off uh would go
to the ward member which is councillor
john ward you sir have five minutes in
which to address the committee
thank you chairman this is an
application for major additions to the
marcus upper lamb
following a long period of line disused
and looking in a sorry state
this traditional country pub was
acquired and given a new lease of life
by mr o'leary
the listed buildings have been
beautifully restored and it is now a
popular restaurant and venue with
accommodation function rooms and a
lovely outdoor terrace overlooking the
brett valley it's the local business
that provides employment as well as
being a significant player in the local
hospitality sector
the applicant now wishes to expand with
a banqueting hall further accommodation
and wellness center
this will be of great importance to the
local economy by providing not just
construction
jobs but also contin continuing business
for local suppliers and of course the
additional permanent jobs
that the expanded business will provide
as you've heard 45 new full
and part-time jobs which is a
substantial number for a rural area like
this
the extra accommodation is also needed
in the area and will support both babies
aspirations to grow hadley as the
destination
and the desire of the south suffolk task
force to build a coherent offering
around the art heritage of the district
which includes
cedric morris's former home at nearby
benton end
suffolk county council highways has
identified measures to mitigate the
impact of the construction and
additional ongoing business traffic
they have spent they've specified access
and parking management requirements
and matters that the construction
management plan must address there were
concerns in the initial response from
place services particularly regarding
the landscape and visual impact of the
new car park and formal gardens
following recommendations changes have
been made which are now acceptable
concerns about lighting and noise
management have also been addressed and
mitigation measures
are acceptable to our environmental
protection team anglian water is
satisfied with the ability of this
sewage system to cope
with the additional flow and the county
council's flood and water management
team has also given approval for the
surface water management and suds
a number of our planning policies relate
to this application but i want to
address how those policies that relate
to the economy support it
saved policy emo1 states
employment-related development proposals
which are not covered by other policies
will be
judged in particular against the
expected job creation the potential
effect on residential immunity
environmental quality traffic generation
and road safety and site accessibility
by a range of transport modes
all these criteria have been addressed
and where requested changes made to
ameliorate any adverse effect
more importantly state policy em 20
states
proposals for the expansion extension of
an existing employment use
site or premises will be permitted
provided there is no material conflict
with residential and environmental
immunity
or highway safety the supporting text
for this actually goes on to say
given a local economy where inward
investment from outside firms is
traditionally low
the protection and promotion of
indigenous businesses take on
an even greater importance in the
interest of providing further employment
opportunities
safeguarding the future of local
businesses and strengthening the local
economy
there will be a strong presumption in
favor of permitting the expansion of an
existing firm or other employer
i couldn't have put it better myself we
need to consider the future of this
excellently-run business and allow it to
expand
the 2014 core strategy is also clear on
the need and benefit of economic growth
and states that our preferred approach
is through an economic growth
job-sled strategy and that there are no
compelling reasons to stifle or impede
this
it also talks of strengthening the rural
economy specifically policy cs3 states
proposals for employment uses that will
contribute to the local economy and
increase the sustainability of core
villages hinterland villages and the
rural economy
will be promoted and supported where
appropriate in scale character and
nature to their locality
policy cs17 also talks of encouraging
sustainable tourism and leisure based
businesses
now as you've heard there are admittedly
a large number of objections to this
application and i do recognize the
legitimate concerns
raised in the parish council statement
today but the issues that objectors
raise regarding traffic
lighting noise visual impact water
management and other matters
have all been addressed and mitigated
and there are now no holding objections
from the statutory consultees
some and we have heard this today also
question the need for a venue such as
this
question its viability and point to
existing competition but these are
subjective opinions and are not material
planning considerations
you will see from the documentation
before you that the applicant has been
very approachable
and willing to take on board
recommendations for improving the
application
and mitigating its impact so that any
potential conflicts between our economic
policies and other planning policies are
resolved
this new venture represents a very
significant investment and faith
in the local economy by the applicant
who is local having been a resident of
raiden for i believe some 30
years the economic benefits are clear
not just locally
but to the whole district thank you
chairman
thank you well done you've had 30
seconds left
right members have you got any questions
to cancel
to the ward member councillor john ward
is any hands down up it doesn't look
like
no okay thank you very much then we'll
move
we'll move on into debate i will now
open the item up 40 mate and again i'd
ask councillors to use the hand
up function um
if not i'm gonna have to start with
alphabetically order
and ask kenzler sue ah we've got
somebody right that's fine
councillor busby you'd like to start
thank jay yes i think first of all i
think it's a shame
that we didn't have a site visit i went
out there
um with lee parker on monday
to to look at the site and you get a
significantly different
perspective of the development when
you're actually on the site
and it would have been worth everybody
on the committee going out there
i mean it's a great presentation by sam
but i still think there are times where
we ought to visit
the sites and this one was one of those
occasions i was pleasantly surprised
when i was there
uh that how the impact wouldn't be as
great as i thought it was going to be
and it's a i think it will be a
sympathetic addition to
the existing buildings which have been
tastefully done and very classically
done
and i think it will be an added benefit
to the area
i'm sure hadley particularly will get a
lot of extra trade
because of it thank you
councillor parker
super thank you very much jeff um yeah i
mean i
i too tend to agree that looking at the
plans
um it's going to it's going to represent
a very sympathetic
um addition to to what is there but
nonetheless
it is a substantial addition and it is
as i said before it's going to change
um the the scenery there forever um
so i'm just wondering if we got anybody
here from from heritage chair at all
because
you know it's interesting on page 14 the
opening comment from the heritage
heritage team um is that the changes to
the proposed extensions are now
almost acceptable um which is which is
not exactly helpful i mean it's a bit
it's a bit
uh ambiguous i mean i i know either
they're acceptable or
or they're not so um i mean sam
mentioned it in her presentation that it
uh offers i think a very low level
of less than substantial harm
but then it does mention um about the
very unsightly substation
which is not appropriate um so um
i'll just be interested to know if we've
got anybody from heritage just be
interested to hear their comments um but
at this point if we've got anyone
i'll see whoever we have i don't believe
we have um
samantha yeah i have just asked uh
jonathan duck to join us
um i don't know whether he will need
someone to let him in uh
robert so he should be able to join
straight away samus he's an officer at
the council okay
uh dr doc have you managed to join us
yes i saw him yesterday you're muted at
the moment sir
uh well done you're unmuted those famous
words
uh did you hear the question from
councillor um parker if not i asked him
to
say it again i didn't i didn't
and i think that's important yeah um so
heritage comments and and the opening
line on the on the
um uh presentation at page 14 says the
changes to the proposed extensions to
the marquis of cornwallis are now
almost acceptable um from a heritage
same perspective so
i made the comment jonathan if you don't
mind that that's um
it's it's somewhat ambiguous um it's
almost acceptable so just be interesting
yeah understood counsellor it is it is
ambiguous
um sometimes we're in a position where
something isn't quite
acceptable and i what i can't say is
hand on heart there is no harm
um because i i i've got to be true to
what i
what i think and there is there is some
harm
um but it's it's for the planning
officers to to weigh the balance
now with the suggestions i made that the
the ridge of the perpendicular range be
lowered
and the substation against the road be
relocated i think that harm could be
diminished as low as it could possibly
be
because i can't say there's no harm
because it is a large extension but
we've been in negotiation a long time
and i think actually it's quite an
exciting scheme but i accept it's very
big
um so what i'm saying is yes there is
harm
we can get it down as low as possible
but given that the the building
is what it is i cannot say there is no
harm
can i just help you both out there it
was comment i think samantha said this
because it's early on in my notes i
wrote down
um less harm low
level which is basically what dr duck
has just said as well
um so i i think that's where we are with
it
okay thank you very much chair thank you
councillor hinton
plexus stay with us dr dark yes
doctor that could stay with us because
he's just mentioned the relocation of
the
substation um
who authorized the relocation of the
substation was it the national
energy provider or or was it uh under
our
auspices because uh the implications
being given that uh the substation has
been put there
uh without
any much say in the matter um but uh if
we can move it a bit surely we can move
it a lot and move it further away from
the building
yes thank you councillor i i to be
honest i i don't know
i don't know i i just noticed that it
had it seems to be relocated and i felt
that was harmful
um i believe uh council hinton um
that the applicants said that it was
national grid that it
asked for to be there because the wire
had to come under the road or something
and that was the best place for it but
if he's put under the
john we've lost you sorry if it's put
under the roadway
from that farm down to the main road and
then comes underneath the b1070
then surely it doesn't it isn't beyond
the width of modern engineering to move
it
100 yards further down the road by the
side of the road to a substation
located further away from the building i
know that national grid are
looking at the moment in increasing the
amount of electricity transmitted across
baber
and that the transmission lines going
across the brettvale are going to be
possibly uh up for ext
expansion again because they've got
somehow or other get rid of all this
electricity that they're generating in
the north sea and get it to where people
actually need it
and that means increasing the the number
of big power lines that go across the
place rather than putting it under the
sea
so whether this is part of that proposal
or what i don't know
but it just seems all a bit mysterious
that all of a sudden
uh substations appeared when nothing
else seems to have been
consulted upon right
uh i i think you made your comments
unless you wanted to add to them
uh dr doc no thank you chair i
i don't i don't thank you right um
samantha can you help us out on what
counselor hinton's just commented on
yeah absolutely um so could i just
ask um dr duck
if screening was put in place around
uh the substation would that
help to minimize its impact
well i think it would mitigate but it
the the guidance that i've been reading
does say
and we have appeal decisions recently
that support the view
that you can't hide something that's
otherwise harmful by by putting trees up
you can mitigate you can diminish the
amount of harm you can reduce it
but you can't get rid of something that
is fundamentally harmful by
by screening so we again would be
lowering that level of harm but we
wouldn't be diminishing
removing it right i think the applicant
made it quite clear
that um moving the substation isn't
actually an option because
uh power networks wanted it in that
location
um so you know the applicant doesn't
particularly want it there because
it impacts uh the reception area for his
hotel
so um but if there is no choice if we
can minimize that somehow by
uh adding adding a condition maybe
to uh to agree some screening whether
that is by
fencing it and planting or just planting
perhaps that may be a way forward
i think um samantha and dr duck the
applicant did say that he didn't like it
there
but he he would do everything in his
powers to screen it and minimize it and
and what have you so i think we can
we can put that in as a condition i
suppose if we were minded to approve
it um but uh i'm going to bring in
mr russell he might be able to help us
out on all this
thank you chair i'm not going to say
much new actually sam covered quite a
lot of space there
yeah the screening is going to help
mitigate but not cancel out the harm
uh what i was going to suggest is that
we have been given a quite strong
version of events that the
the power um operator says it's got to
go there
um so we shouldn't go away from here
with a condition saying
relocate the substation i don't think we
can do that what we can do if you are
strongly minded we can
at least if you could defer to us a
discussion we could have with them
to see if it could indeed be moved at
all i get the impression it couldn't but
why don't we at least have that
discussion
um and if we can't then it stays where
it is but we'll make sure the
landscaping scheme which we've got a
condition for
uh incorporates a screening as much as
possible off of the substation
sounds very good um canceller
as you are next
counselor airs
there we go yes thank you chair um
further
um from um council awards
um comments and i too feel that um
it would really enhance the area because
um
you think they're not very far from the
a12 we've got
the dead and veil everything to do with
the painted constable
and then we're having this gallery
extension um for gainsborough's house
which again isn't too far
and and to have a sort of a hotel there
i think would just be
marvellous and i i really would
would support it thank you thank you
very much
councillor osborne
thank you thank you mr chairman i just i
really need some clarification here um
you're talking about relocation of the
transformer well
to my knowledge or to what i've heard
it's a new
uh transformer set up to go into
that car park if there if it is a
relocation
where is it at the moment you know i i
i did uh answer ask this earlier on
uh at the beginning of the clarification
with the officer but
i can't see any any uh situation in
there where
well i don't believe i don't believe
that this
is a relocation but i'll ask the case
officer
samantha can you help out on this point
for councillor osborne
um could we go back to the applicant and
ask that question please
right uh members are you happy that i
put this question to the applicant
because if
if you're not yet right okay um
[Music]
right applicant where are you perhaps
you can come back mr o'leary
can you on this point only can you
answer
is this a relocation no it's um
an increase of power right does that
help you ken slothsborn
uh well it does because in fact um
the power that power source that they
have at the moment as obviously from the
old
the old setup from the old pub areas and
uh they didn't need probably didn't need
a i'm only assuming this
that they didn't need a a substation but
now
with it with with an increase in power
which would be
quite considerable obviously they've had
to
go for a for a new substation which is
probably the advice of any
energy uh company that are going to
come into this the other the other the
other point about it all is
um with this uh
you know it's going to have to have
obviously
i'm absolutely in agreement with you
about the about the
screening around it however these
substations
do fall into problems at some point or
another
and so there will be need for access to
it so i
you know i'll be happy to to see it
screen well screen
however there is a situation where they
will need probably
access to it but that is for the
obviously that would
that would be taken into consideration
canceler i was born i would think to any
screen and if there was
a play for uh thank you mr
larry i'll just just add that uh as
councillor airs i'm i'm very happy with
this
particularly with the improvement that
it'll have for hadley itself
it's just the sort of thing that sudbury
unfortunately
have neglected to have in you know in
their
hotel set setups but um
yeah i'm i'm i'm in favor of this
application
as it stands thank you thank you
councillor barrett you're next
thank you very much jen um i i
just uh also like um councillor busby i
drove out and had a look uh because i
was a little bit concerned about the
impact across the the valley as it's a
open um for some some distance um and i
i believe that you know the the
disruption to
views from across the valley are can be
minimized and are
quite a significant distance as well so
with sympathetic
materials i think that that will look
good in the setting
um and i was very impressed also with
the
the appearance and the sympathetic
treatment that had already
taken place with the the um upgrade that
took place
so i you know i i thought that um
uh that if that is continued that sort
of style
it will provide a very attractive um
venue
and it really is the sort of um
thing that people expect these days a
very high standard of accommodation
so although we've heard about viability
i think um
you know i know no local businessmen who
who believe that we
you you you invest but you don't
necessarily see a return for some time
and that's to be expected so
i don't have concerns about that um
i just probably should have asked
earlier but i
wondered about licensing and operation
times
should is that just something that is
devolved to the licensing committee
or yes that's not our concern here that
would have to go to license and i'm
correct there robert and am i not
you'll go to help uh thank you chair
rather than myself give
as i'm not an expert on the licensing mr
prey is i would ask for his idea
okay yes you're very kind mister michael
i did do a lot of licensing in my last
job yes i mean i
it did run through my mind but yes the
principles of law relevant here is
um this council is a pla the local
planning authority and the licensing
authority the two
are are they're administered by the same
council but they're separate
jurisdictions i'm i dare say
this establishment as well as having
planning permission for what's there at
the moment
has um a license a premises license
under the licensing act 2003 for the
sale of alcohol and very likely for
public entertainment possibly late night
refreshment which is
hot food and drink between 11 00 uh
p.m and 5 a.m in the morning um it would
i mean i would or if
if i was on the other side of the fence
i'd i would
and i think i i would ask if i was i'd
suggest the council recommended to
anyone who asked that if
it's often wise to sort out planning
before you sort out licensing but it's
up to the applicant they can do it
either way around if they wish
i don't know whether whether these
proposals would
they might require adjustments to the
premises license
if there are new um buildings are going
to be
the the site of licensable activities
that may very well be the case
or if they want to adjust the hours or
conditions but yes they would have to
make
an application to the council as
licensing authority and if they were
actually what one thing that's worth
saying is whereas with planning law
there's a lot of discretion
how we make our decisions licensing law
if there's any if there's only one
representation made locally
then there has to be a licensing hearing
of
usually a subcommittee of three people
councillors from
licensing committee to deal with it so
that would that would be dealt with in
that way
and the the statutory guidance says very
clearly that licensing
the licensing authority the licensing
committee is not automatically obliged
to follow the decision of the planning
committee
so i don't know that that hopefully
that's a bit of help yeah
very helpful thank you very much no i i
just wanted to say i
i you think i think all the the um
the presentation and what we've heard
has shown that there is a
um there is it's a good scheme and it's
it's going to benefit the area and it's
it's um
you know i'm happy to support it
thank you uh councillor jameson
okay uh thank you yes he's probably two
should be directed to sam probably i
haven't seen i can't see any
um conditions relating to the
environmental
um performance of the building
i just wondered is this going to be
included in the construction
um management plan or is this something
to be
that should be added or or is it
somewhere else that i'm missing
i think all new build has to come under
certain regulations but i'm sure
samantha can tell us yeah so quite a lot
of it would be covered by building
regulations
um if if you're specifically talking
about a sustainability
condition uh that isn't included at the
moment
there is something that members could
add as a condition
if you wished
parker
um thank you just a really quick
question if members were minded to
support this application if we got any
indication of
how quickly development would uh would
commence
very good point uh samantha can you help
um my understanding is that the
applicant wants to get on as soon as
possible
he wasn't expecting the application
process to be
as prolonged as it has been as
you know because of design issues and
then ecology
landscaping issues have cropped up
during during
the application process i think he was
hoping to have
really got started at late summer at the
latest
so um i think he is very keen to get on
um i'm not sure what his time frames are
and whether he has a builder lined up
[Music]
we can shorten the time
limit for commencement if members felt
that that was necessary
but if he's keen to get going anyway
is there really a need to put a time on
it other than the three years
thank you uh councillor mclaren
thank you chair um i just uh
want to say that considering
the last year and all of us represent
parishes that have hospitality as part
of the
economy i think this is a welcome
uh development and i fully support it
and i was especially um impressed by mr
o'leary's
consideration of staff and the
development of staff
that really was quite um
helpful thank you thank you
uh councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman just um just a
couple of quick ones as uh
councillor hinton always says um
restriction on [ __ ] construction working
hours
uh have we have we uh have with that in
mind have we
the working hours in mind or is this
something that's got to be worked
out uh samantha we'll take that one
first
um certainly that can be a condition um
linda is now exiting
um we we shouldn't add on conditions
just for the sake of adding on
conditions
um is uncomfortable
um is it on or isn't it
or what does it cover yeah just let me
there's quite a lot of conditions i just
need to have a quick look through but i
think councillor osborne has just said
that there is
and i thought there was um that's right
so
as taking care of them we'll let you
look for that while you ask your second
question
yeah it's definitely on their
restriction construction working hours
so that will be picked up
thank you all right so would would you
be able to tell us what the
what the restrictions would be on
working out yeah
normally um it's eight till six
um and no deliveries outside of those
times
on saturdays uh that would be restricted
from
eight till two um and nothing on sundays
or bank holidays
thank you very much um just just on the
other one um
a noise management plan i've never seen
one of those on a
on a condition i'm not happy with all of
these conditions going on
on an application however they are
needed i
i quite agree but the problem is it's
the enforcement of them and what
would happen if the enforcement fails to
uh
to be able to um mitigate the
the problems of the residents around it
and
this is a situation which we as
councillors often get
in terms of people asking uh why they
are still doing this and
they've gone against what they've
already been put down as a
as a condition so you know i'm a bit
concerned about that position but
all in all i think um this is a welcome
uh welcome part of the economy and um mr
o'leary is
is is what i consider a person that will
keep to his word
thank you thank you there's no other
hands up
um i've had lots of you say that you
support this but i haven't had any
proposal for
or against so i'm coming back to you
members
uh councillor busby
yes sir i'll propose that we accept the
recommendations of the planning officer
thank you very much i have a second of
that councillor parker you were next
uh yes chair i'm perfectly happy to
accept that uh recommend or second that
recommendation
jeff thank you and that's the um
officers recommendations with the
proposals as they are uh mr russell
i just want to check two things came up
in discussion and some members might
have thought that would go to resolution
i just want to check we mentioned
briefly
us talking to the um operator to see
whether the substation could be
relocated i suspect we'll have a fallow
discussion and it won't get moved
but did you want that to go to the
recommendation i i think we've already
been told that that isn't like
okay and
less members of particular on that um i
think we've had quite a lot of
discussion
and i i got the impression that the
applicant
will do his very best to conform with
any
screening that you want because he don't
like it any more than we do
right um but unless members of
got a different feeling on that and your
second point the second point was
a mention of sustainability measures
which was brought up or won the members
do we add that to the list of conditions
uh
well i think councillor barrett answered
that um
that we we was more or less satisfied in
the present climate
and with what they've told us uh how
they've been operating over the last
two or three years um but uh
members there's no other hands going up
about that either oh yes i've got one
now councillor jameson
uh yeah it was coming on that yeah it
was about the sustainability measures
i'm not sure
what what you saying they've met them
already he said
excuse me were we talking about the same
thing here
our sustainability was uh um
whether it was going to have a future no
no no sorry sustainable construction as
in you know
the green side of things i thought that
was the the point that was raised by the
councillor
well i thought lots of the green issues
were already in the list of conditions
well i can't see anything on there about
the actual build itself so what more do
you want in the build itself
well as close to um
as best as we can get normally we have
sometimes we have a sustainability
management plan
can you help out on this whether we need
that i don't know
right we'll check samantha
um it's not uncommon uncommon to have
um a sustainable build condition
it certainly is something that we could
add it talks about
water consumption electricity
insulation that type of thing it just
depends if
uh councillors feel that that is
necessary or whether the building rigs
would actually surely they're picked up
under building rigs the
insulation and the water and this sort
of thing
um most times i hear of building they
say that these are very strict
on what new conditions they have to put
in but um
[Music]
i i don't know whether there's any
necessity to add any more conditions to
it
but remember this is up to you then why
do we have them
on other planning applications if
they're not needed didn't say they were
not needed i said they're in the
conditions that um
have already been explained to us by
samantha there
um mr russell yeah it was just that just
to
remind members of what had been
discussed and if they wanted to put that
to resolution if
it's not the case for the point then
that's fine please carry on i'm
sorry i interrupted chair right yeah mr
mr chairman i'll just make a point here
that mr o'leary did make reference
to the uh sustainability of the of the
build
and he will be doing what when it comes
forward
uh with his builders he will be partly
involved in get making sure that
the sustainability of of of that build
will be
eco right thank you um
robert
thank you jill um just to sort of move
things along in the sense of procedural
matter um if we could go back
and ask the proposer and seconder
whether
to whether they want to add any
conditions and then um
i think that would move us a long share
in the sense of that
yes councillor busby do you wish to add
any more conditions
are you satisfied with what's being said
i don't think we need to add any more i
think the quality of the build
uh will be reflected by what's
already there so uh kenzala parker are
you happy
yeah absolutely concur thank you thank
you right they don't wish to
um so unless there's any other new pints
that members want to bring up
i intend to uh put this to the vote in a
moment
no right um so we're
um proposing that we accept the
officer's recommendation
as laid out in the papers uh proposed by
councillor busby seconded by councillor
parker
i'll now ask robert carmichael if he'll
take us through the electronic vote
procedure
thank you thank you chair and i'll just
confirm mr russell that
the recommendation reads as follows the
application
dc twenty slash zero one five one seven
be approved as detailed in the office of
recommendation
just confirm that that is what you have
as well thank you very much
so members and the vote is now in
progress so if mems could please go to
the modern.gov app
and go to the plus in the top right hand
corner
of today's agenda and then if you click
on
the voting slash attendance subsection
and that will take you to the voting tab
before us where the vote is in progress
and showing us a light
blue color
all right just gotta scroll down
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and i confirm that
the nine votes four have been received
and one vote against so the motion is
carried
thank you very much all right members
um we'll move on um
now we're it's 11 35
do members want to take a 10 minute
comfort break or do you want to carry on
to deal with the next item which
i would have thought would be reasonably
straightforward kenzler busby
i propose that we accept the officers
recommendations
right so we're carrying on um
our second hand mr chairman that's
counsellor i was born
well members um i think i'm gonna have
to ask
robert or somebody do we need the case
officer just to
uh do the outline i think we do sure i
would i would have that i would um
because we've got to go through these i
was going to say to go through best
practice we should
go through the presentation and we do
have
other speakers here to be heard from
first before we have
um go into debate so
if we go through the normal process i
believe that that would um
in that case i'm going to
use an executive decision and say that
we're going to take a break and come
back at quarter to 12
and we'll do the final application very
sorry because
it must be that's fine though i'm happy
if we're going to debate it then i'll
remove my
recommendation in that case thank you
members uh perhaps your
help take a break now and we'll come
back at quarter to 12. thank you very
much
uh welcome back members
um right i'm going to ask robert to give
her do a roll call of
all participants okay thank you chair
so councillor suez hello i'm back
councillor barrett yes i'm here
councillor busby
yep here that's the hinton president
council jameson
yeah councillor mclaren crescent council
osborne
claims that i was born
come back to him yep councillor parker
present cancer plum present
so councillor osborne are you with us
wouldn't check the members of public if
they're present yep
so mr o'leary can you confirm that you
can still hear us and that you're back
yes i can hear you yet thank you very
much and mr hardwick
yes i can hear you thank you very much
and we've got um mr curran just to
confirm i
are you speaking on the next application
because i have confirmation from
um the clock that you weren't speaking
on the next one could i just confirm
that or
right yes i'm not speaking i'm listening
in there if you don't mind
yep that's absolutely fine sir thank you
very much uh
councillor osborne could just confirm
that you can hear us and see us yes uh
sorry robert i
i i'd gone into my emails and uh i
couldn't get
back as quick as uh you were asking
sorry about that
multiple tasks you cannot multitask
counselor i was born
i try i try
right thank you uh right then we'll move
on
uh 6b uh lame um
suffolk listed building consent samantha
thank you chair um
so this is only uh for the list of
building consent uh dc201518
um the description is for extensions to
provide
additional facilities including
reception banquet hall
wellness center and additional bedrooms
so unlike the previous
application for full planning permission
we're not considering
the extension into the field it is
literally
just what's happening here with the
extensions because that concerns the
listed building
um i think we've probably already
covered everything um
so less than substantial harm has been
raised
mainly because of the location of
the uh substation the
public benefits outweigh the
uh less than substantial harm because of
the creation of jobs
and the retention of an existing
building and it's an
and its extension thank you
members is there any points of
clarification
that you wish to ask samantha the case
officer sorry
no hands up
no you're quite
chairman sorry yeah counselor hint on it
yes your hands are feared
a bit slow getting my little button
just just a quick one for samantha i
noticed on page 36 of the report
the comments from the society for
protection of ancient buildings
while we appreciate that an attempt has
been made to address these concerns
notably by stepping down a section of
the roof line
the fact remains that the extension is
simply disproportionately large
in relation to the main building is that
this
part of the lesson substantial harm or
are we only concerned with the
substation when it comes to substantial
harm the less than substantial harm has
been raised by
our heritage team not by the society for
the protection of
ancient buildings so um
if their comments are in conflict with
each other
so we would take our expert advice from
our heritage officers
because they're always right and they're
always wrong uh
no cause it's a grade two listed
building um it's rather like
um historic england
where if if they uh object to an
application
um often we can override their decision
unless it's a grade
two star or a grade one listed building
thank you any other points
anybody want to raise no
right we'll move on then
uh public speakers um the parish council
uh hasn't uh got a speaker
um but we have uh
richard cranfield for as an objector you
have three minutes in which to address
the committee
oh geez chair i don't think mr cranfield
is with us anymore who's he spoke as the
earlier one um he did it
i was just checking my emails chair just
to confirm that he did wish to speak on
both so
um well i can come back to him at the
end yeah i will drop him an email
urgently because i don't have a phone
number and ask him
to um join the meeting if he still
wishes to speak if that's acceptable to
you chair yeah
and mr prairie is our um legal advice if
that's
acceptable it's i'm here as legal
advisor yeah yes that seems fine to me i
did notice that mr
cranfield his name disappeared from the
list of attendees
soon after we uh finished the uh the
speaking on the first
that's what yeah it's quite right to
check yes i agree with that
right do i do i need to wait and find
out whether he's going to speak
uh because there is an order isn't there
a procedure
here and to add him back
after the ward member wouldn't be the
right idea i don't think uh that's uh
your discretion chair
is the is the honest answer there there
is
um before we go to the ward member i'll
see if he's
rejoined us okay and if he wants to
speak
so we'll move on to a supporter
which is linda keenan um
are you with us still i think linda
keenan might
have might have left earlier as per the
other point
i wasn't clear whether she wished to
speak in both both supported capacities
so i would assume that following on from
the speech earlier chair that that might
have been just for the first one
yeah i will then move to
the next part which is the applicant to
speak stephen o'leary well i know he's
with us
so i do say i have three minutes in
which to address the committee
so um
when you're ready set i think um we all
assumed
that the first three minutes was the
only three minutes and i think that's
probably why people have left
from my point of view no just uh sorry
to come in there they'll stop the clock
um mr carmichael would have made it
quite clear
that there was three minutes for each
one
um each application because there were
two separate applications
and five minutes for the ward members on
each application
okay and i think they chose not to from
what um
we're thinking now but anyway you are
here so we'll
carry on with you um thank you very much
um yeah from my point of view we
will continue to um use the best
materials that we can
to keep the history of this uh building
going really we're going to go to uh
bulma
um to to get their soft red bricks which
is is
um a fantastic feature of what we've
already
got we're obviously down with english
oak as well
um the substation um
again and i i'm more than happy to uh
to speak to to network power and tell
them how
um how
unhappy we all are with where they
where they want to cite this and i will
see whether we can't get it moved
we we do have an issue which is that
there was a covenant on the car park
and that the covenant has been lifted
for only the barriers of the
planning application that we have um
obviously i can speak
to the farmer and see whether
he's willing to allow us to put this
somewhere else but
that i will use all my abilities to see
what we can do a network
and get that thing moved um i suppose
from my point of view it's a slight
oversight
you know we were we were more worried
about
getting you know the general um planning
application through
um and i haven't concentrated my powers
on that but i'll
i'll give it a go and see where we can
go um but again
you know the whole thing about this
being a venue
and being the destination is how i can
keep it in character that is really
the the big part of this for me and
thank you very much
thank you i'll see if there's any
questions for you
i've just got one quick one how quickly
would you
start um once you've got the
um all the legal bits and that in place
yeah i mean i think the restriction on
when i can start it's going to come from
samantha you know i'm
as said i was hoping to have got
the car park done last september um
but because of you know issues and covid
you know we're behind time i i i wanted
to try and get
the major part of the building done um
in the winter months
you know so it's going to start
september go through so now we'll build
the car park straight away
and once we've got the car apart we can
then work out how we can
manage um the processes to see whether
we've got shut down for a short period
or whether we could work through
and we get our customers from the car
park past the building site
um so my answer is straight away
all right very good thank you and
hopefully you don't have to shut down
for too much longer
particularly for a lot of shutdowns uh
at the moment
well i'm watching the weather forecast
for next week and it's not very good and
obviously we've got to be outside so
yeah thank you members any other
questions there's no other hands up
no okay uh thank you then mr o'leary i'm
gonna go back to robert now and see
whether any of the other two
uh public speakers have rejoined us
no chair um we don't have other i've
emailed
right um ian can i ask you now
uh i think i'm quite all right to carry
on now i really think so chairman i
think if either of them anyone had had a
bit of an i.t disaster there'd be some
other means they could have communicated
with with roberts or with any of us
and i think it's it's fair that you
should carry on yes thank you very much
members i intend to carry on so we're
now go
to the ward member which is councillor
john
ward uh you sir have five minutes in
which to address the committee
thank you chairman i won't need that
i'll be very
very brief as i don't really have more
to say about the heritage
heritage aspects from from what sam
summers has already said
but i will make a few comments the new
construction has been designed to blend
in with and complement the two listed
buildings very sympathetically
there has been a huge amount of effort
put into achieving this with extensive
dialogue with our heritage team
the applicant has listened to advice and
made changes to ensure that the new
structure retains the visual and
architectural prominence of the listed
buildings
whilst there are still a few concerns
regarding the substation as you will
ever heard
the overall heritage assessment is that
the design is attractive
and as stated in the latest heritage
latest heritage response
and confirmed today by dr dupp there is
considered now to be a very
low level of less than substantial harm
and that this
should be weighed against the public
benefits of the application
which are significant and that's that's
really all i wanted to add thanks
chairman
thank you very much i'll serve as any
questions for you council award
members have you got any questions for
councillor ward
or are you going to let him off lightly
right no questions for you no hands have
gone up okay so
we'll go into debate uh cancel a buzz
beat
well i haven't really got anything to
say i'm happy to listen to anybody else
i know i think i've said it all
right does anybody
wish to comment or anything
uh counselor barrett
i think we could just go to the vote
really because i think we've
explored all the areas in one big
package really in the the first
application
so i i don't think there's really
anything else that that we have
haven't said really but i'm pleased to
hear about bulmer bricks that's really
good
good because that's very local very in
keeping
i can't put words in your mouth but uh
you're all very supportive but nothing
else has come forward
um i propose we
you'll make the proposal to accept the
officer's recommendation is that correct
thank you well councillor parker had his
hand up next are you second in this
councillor parker
i'm happy to second that chair thank you
right
thank you uh any other comments
oh councillor osborne
yes thank you um yes i was prepared to
second or
propose that um i'm quite happy with it
i think it's a
i think it's a long overdue i can
remember that pub being out of
out of touch for many years uh when i
used to come down and play cricket round
here
um the only thing i can say is that
the presentation and particularly the
uh the paperwork we've had for this
uh planning application has been
excellently done by
osborne i'm going to stop you there i
know exactly what you're saying
you've already said that earlier i think
we can move on
unless you've got anything relevant
about the um
this particular part of the application
um
i'm going to move on any other comments
members
no right has been proposed and seconded
sorry proposed by uh councillor barrett
seconded by councillor parker to accept
the officer's recommendation
robert would you like to take us through
the electronic vote
thank you chair i'll just read it out
for clarity so that all members are
aware
so um the proposal that's on the table
is that application dc
20 015 to be approved as detailed in the
office recommendation
so i will now start the electronic vote
so if members could please go to today's
agenda
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner which will bring up the
subsection on voting slash attendance
if you click on that it will bring up
all the votes for today's meeting
and the meeting that the vote that is
now in progress will be shown in a light
blue
color
ugh
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and i can confirm that the vote
is
nine votes for and one against so the
motion is carried
thank you very much uh right members i
think we've got to the
end of the agenda um so
looking at that uh next meeting um
should be on wednesday the 21st
of april and
i think there's another one due on the
4th of may um which we're looking into
because i know that clashes with a lot
of members diaries
um so um keep an eye on your emails to
see whether
either of these two meetings are going
to happen i think the
21st may do but i'm not sure about them
may
the fourth one okay thank you then
members thank you very much for your
attendance
and i'd like to declare them